but first let me just say a few words
about the story that I know many of you
are tracking
I was first briefed on the reports of
unauthorized disclosure of sensitive and
classified material
on the morning of April 6th
and since then I've been convening
senior department leaders daily on our
response
and I've directed an urgent
cross-department effort
and we've referred the matter to the
Department of Justice
which has opened a criminal
investigation
now I can't say much more while the
Justice Department's investigation is
ongoing
but we take this very seriously
and we will continue to work closely
with our outstanding allies and partners
and nothing will ever stop us from
keeping America secure the documents
that uh
that we are aware of are dated the 28th
of February 1st of March
I don't know if there are other
documents that are that have been online
before these are things that we will
find find out as we continue to
investigate but uh but the documents
that we are focused on thus far 28th of
February and the first of March again we
will continue to investigate and and try
to determine the full scope of uh of the
activity well there were somewhere in
the in the web uh and uh and where
exactly and who had access uh at that
point uh we we don't know we simply
don't know at this point so uh and again
I won't speculate Andrea I will tell you
that we take this very seriously and we
will continue to investigate and and
turn over every rock until we find the
source of this and the extent of it so
the
the issue of maintaining the security of
information is critical to the
development of national capability and
to the trust and confidence across
allies and partners
and I appreciate that uh
this by reports is a serious leak it is
being investigated
seriously by U.S authorities and they
are engaging with Partners in order to
better understand the potential
consequences of that information being
released into the public
anything
that undermines the security the
stability and the prosperity of the
indo-pacific region in which we live
ease of interest to Australia
the question then might arise what
particular circumstance or scenario
enlivens what form of interest and in
what form of response
I encourage all parties to areas of
international tension
to find other ways
to resolve that tension
conflict is
sometimes it may be necessary as the
absolute Last Resort
but Shakespeare got it right when you
unleash the dogs of war
you can't necessarily be confident to
contain the outcome and as I say a a
stable secure free and open indo-pacific
for all nations
is in Australia's interest
20 seconds